>> THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WANTED FOR
KILLING A POLICE OFFICER IN
CALIFORNIA ARRESTED AFTER A
MASSIVE 48 HOURS MANHUNT.
THE SHERIFF BLAMED SANCTUARY
LAWS SAYING THE SUSPECT HAD 2
PREVIOUS DUI ARRESTS.
AND IF HE WAS DEPORTED OFFICER
RON SINGH WOULD STILL BE ALIVE.
SAYING THE SUSPECT WAS TRYING TO
FLEE TO MEXICO.
TWO OTHERS WERE ARRESTED FOR
HELPING THE SUSPECTED MURDERER
EVADE CAPTURE.
POLICE ANNOUNCED THIS AT AN
EMOTION PRESS CONFERENCE WITH
VICTIM'S PLAYERS.
>> THE SUSPECT WAS HAPPEN HENDED
IN BAKERSFIELD AND TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY TODAY BY TEAMS FROM THE
KERN COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
WHO HELPED US PURSUE THIS
SUSPECT IN PURSUIT OF JUSTICE.
GUSTAVO PEREZ ARRIAGA, 33 YEARS
OLD, AGAIN WAS ARRESTED DURING
THE EXECUTION OF A SEARCH
WARRANT.
HE WAS FOUND IN A RESIDENCE IN
BAKERSFIELD.
WE WILL GET INTO THE SPECIFICS
OF THAT.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE OFFICER RON
SINGH'S BROTHER REGGIE.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A FEW
WORDS WITH ALL OF YOU.
>> [VOICE BREAKING].
PLEASE BEAR WITH ME.
THIS IS NOT EASY FOR ME.
[CRYING].
HE WAS MY BROTHER.
YES, HE IS NOT COMING BACK.
BUT -- [CRYING] -- THERE IS A
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT
MISSES HIM.
[CRYING].
A LOT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE
THAT I DON'T KNOW WHO WORKED
DAYS AND NIGHTS TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FROM
THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART.
YOU MADE THIS HAPPEN.
I WISH I COULD THANK ALL OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
HOMELAND SECURITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND EVERYONE,
BAKERSFIELD TEAM.
I WAS WAITING FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN.
[CRYING].
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
WORKING DAY AND NIGHT TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN.
[CRYING].
>> THANK YOU.
>> DEVASTATING.
GREG, WHAT DOES THIS DO TO OUR
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AND THE BORDER WALL?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT'S OBVIOUSLY
TRAGIC, BUT IT'S INFURIATING
BECAUSE IT WAS PREVENTIBLE.
IF YOU STICK TO THE FACTS.
AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WAS PART OF
A STREET GANG.
HE HAD A COUPLE OF ARRESTS AND
MURDER A POLICE OFFICER ON
CHRISTMAS DAY.
YOU CAN SAY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE LESS VIOLENT THAN THE PEOPLE
BORN HERE.
THAT'S FINE.
MORE AMERICANS DIE FROM HEART
DECEASE THAN FROM CANCER.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T
FIGHT CANCER.
THAT ARGUMENT GOES AWAY.
IF YOU PREVENTED HIS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, YOU WOULD HAVE A
GOOD POLICE OFFICER STILL ALIVE.
THE MEDIA WILL ACCUSE PEOPLE
LIKE US OF USING A TRAGEDY TO
IMPACT POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
WHERE DID WE LEARN THAT FROM?
EVERY MASS SHOOTING IS LINKED TO
LACK OF GUN CONTROL.
THE CHILD OF AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT ATTEMPTS TO CROSS THE
COUNTRY AND ENDS UP THE
HOSPITAL, IT'S BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
TREAT THESE PEOPLE CORRECTLY.
WE LEARNED THIS.
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE USING THESE
TRAGEDIES.
WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO?
THIS IS PREVENTIBLE.
WHAT IS INFURIATING, IT HAPPENED
WHILE WE WERE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION.
WE HAVE BEEN HAVING THIS ROLLING
DISCUSSION FOR 2 YEARS ABOUT
THIS.
IT HAPPENED.
IF ONLY SOMEONE HAD LISTENED TO
US BEFORE HE WOULD BE ALIVE.
IT'S SOMETHING -- PEOPLE GO YOU
ARE USING THIS.
NO, THIS IS EVIDENCE THAT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
>> MARIE?
>> I THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
THIS WEEK WITH THIS CASE AND ONE
OF THE CASES GREG MENTIONED, THE
CHILDREN WHO DIED IN CUSTODY,
AND KATE IN SAN FRANCISCO, THE
COUNTLESS STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO
GO TO GREAT PHYSICAL DANGERS TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY, IS THAT
THE LACK OF AN IMMIGRATION
POLICY THAT WORKS IN THIS
COUNTRY IS TRAGIC AND HEART
BREAKING.
IT HAS TRAGED
IT HAS TRAGIC CONSEQUENCE.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARGUE THAT SANCTUARY CITY
PROTECT PEOPLE JUST LIKE THIS.
NOT HARD-WORKING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS DOING TO GET A
FOOTHOLD IN THE COUNTRY TO MAKE
LIVES BETTER FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT FOR PEOPLE LIKE THIS WHO
HAVE PRIOR ARRESTS AND SHOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN IN THE COUNTRY AND
PUTTING LIVES AT RISK WITH DUI
ARRESTS.
THEY ARE SHIELDED?
>> WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
EVERYTHING.
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
SOLUTIONS WOULD BE.
IS A BORDER WALL A SOLUTION?
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS FROM TEXAS
WHO SAID IT WOULD NOT BE A GOOD
SOLUTION.
THERE ARE SMART PEOPLE WHO NOT
BELIEVE THIS IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION.
IS CRACKING DOWN ON SANCTUARY
CITIES HAVE AN IMPACT?
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER.
WHAT IS SO FRUSTRATING ABOUT
THIS SHUTDOWN WE ARE OBSESSED
WITH THIS ONE THING.
THE WALL.
CAN WE GET DACA FOR THE WALL,
WHICH I THINK WOULD BE A GOOD
TRADEOFF.
IS THE WALL THE RIGHT THING?
WHAT ROLE DO SANCTUARY CITY
PLAY?
WHAT ABOUT DACA?
WHAT ABOUT VISA OVER-STAGING
WHICH IS A HUGE PROBLEM?
THAT'S TRAGIC.
WE GET BOGGED DOWN IN THE
DAY-TO-DAY.
BOTH SIDES GO TO EQUAL EXTREME
OPPOSITES AND NOBODY COMES TO
THE MIDDLE.
>> WE KNOW THAT MEXICO WON'T PAY
FOR THE WALL AND WE WON'T HAVE A
WALL OVER THE ENTIRE BORDER.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
BOTH SIDES KNOW THIS WON'T
HAPPEN.
WE KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO GET SOME TYPE OF BORDER
SECURITY.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY IN A LITTLE BIT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS OFFICER.
THIS IS TRAGIC.
THIS HAPPENED AT CHRISTMAS TIME.
EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT FAMILY IN
THE COUNTRY FEARS THAT.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST FEAR, THAT
THE PERSON YOU LOVE WHO WEARS A
UNIFORM TO KEEP OTHERS SAFE IS
NOT GOING TO COME HOME.
HIS FAMILY AND DEPARTMENT ARE
DEVASTATING.
ARE WE HAVING THE RIGHT
CONVERSATION?
>> THAT'S A GREAT POINT LOOKING
AT A 5-MONTH-OLD AND WATCHING
THE VIDEO.
PEOPLE FORGET THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ARE A
FAMILY.
THEY GO OUT EVERY DAY AND RISK
THEIR LIVES.
THERE IS NO WAY YOU COULD WATCH
THIS AND SOMEHOW STEP BACK AND
DEFEND SANCTUARY CITIES.
THAT'S A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT SHOULD NOT BE
HAPPENING.
THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE DEBATE ON
IMMIGRATION AND EVEN THE WALL.
YOU WILL WATCH THIS AND DEFEND A
SANCTUARY CITY AND MAYORS LIKE
THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND WHO
LAMBASTES "ICE" AND SAYS I WILL
GIVE YOU A WARNING TO PROTECT
YOU FROM "ICE."
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
WITH A KNOWN RECORD WHICH THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO EXIST HERE.
YOU HAVE TO PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO GET HERE AND NOT
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
>> PART OF WHAT SHE IS SAYING
DID YOU NEED A BETTER SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNMENT FAILED TERMS OF
IMMIGRATION.
THIS GUYS KNOWS IF HE WAS
ARRESTED HE WOULD BE DEPORTED.
IT WOULD BE HIS 3rd DUI ARREST
AND HE HAS A GANG TATTOO ON HIS
ARM.
>> CRIMES LIKE THIS HAPPEN
BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE A SYMBOLIC
STANCE.
A SANCTUARY CITY IS A SYMBOLIC
SYSTEM.
NEVER MIND THAT ELEVATES RISK.
THE WHOLE THING IS A TRAVESTY
BECAUSE IT'S DESIGNED TO MAKE
CERTAIN PEOPLE FEEL BETTER WHILE
YOU PAY THE PRICE.
>> WHEN THE MEDIA COFFERS THIS.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THE HEADLINES
OF THIS STORY.VERS THIS.
OF THIS STORY.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TRUMP VILIFIED
EVERY DAY FOR TALKING ABOUT THE
WALL AND DRUG TRAFFICKING AND
GANG VIOLENCE.
>> DO WE KNOW HE CAME IN THROUGH
AN ILLEGAL PORT OF ENTRY?
>> THE DETAILS ARE STILL
EMERGING.
A POLICE OFFICER KILLED BY A
CITIZEN IS ALSO TRAGIC.
BOTH SIDES ARE GOOD AT VILIFYING
THE OTHER.
THESE CHILDREN THAT ARE DYING IN
DHS CUSTODY.
THAT HAS TO STOP.
>> THE SECOND ONE WAS IN A
HOSPITAL.
THAT'S PEOPLE TRYING TO SAVE
THEIR LIVES.
>> YOU --
>> NO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> UNDER OUR LAWS, SHOWING UP
AND APPLYING FOR ASYLUM IS STILL
LEGAL.
IF WE WANT TO MAKE THAT ILLEGAL,
WE CAN CHANGE THE LAWS.
THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IN OUR
COUNTRY NEEDS FIXING.
>> IT DOES.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> [SHOUTING].
>> WHY ISN'T NANCY PELOSI SAYING
THE FIRST THING WE ARE GOING TO
DO IS FIX IMMIGRATION?
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT THE
SHUTDOWN IN THE PRESIDENT'S FACE
TO SHOW THEY ARE RESISTING.
RESISTING IS NOT FIXING
IMMIGRATION.
>> THEY ARE NOT GETTING PAID
BECAUSE OF THE SHUTDOWN.
>> I WAS THE TIMES MAN OF THE
YEAR.
WE HAVE SEEN A 12% INCREASE IN
POLICE KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY FROM 2018.
THAT'S WHERE THE RISK IS.
IN EVERY ONE OF THESE STORIES,